Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. Or, if you're listening on the Apple Podcasts app, you can subscribe within the app in just a few clicks. Hello. In the 6th century AD, the Eastern Roman historian Procopius described the advent of a plague by which, he said, the whole human race came near to being annihilated. He first heard
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。若想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告广播、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。若想收听加更节目、抢先体验、无广告广播以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。或者，如果您在使用 Apple Podcasts 应用，只需点击几下即可在应用内订阅。您好。公元 6 世纪，东罗马历史学家普罗科匹厄斯描述了一场瘟疫的降临，他称这场瘟疫几乎让整个人类险些灭绝。他最初听说
of it in Egypt, but then it spread and soon it reached the imperial capital in Constantinople. There, he wrote, people were seized by the disease before they knew what was coming. They came down with a fever, developed painful swellings and fell into delirium or even a coma. Before long, hundreds of people were dying every day, then thousands and then 10,000. The empire itself seemed shaken to its foundations. And for this calamity, wrote Procopius, it is quite impossible to write or think of any explanation except to refer it to God. Tom Holland, you're always very keen to refer explanations to God in this podcast. Do you think this was an act of God or do you think there's more to it than that? I think there may be more to it. Yeah. And I'm delighted to say
这件事是在埃及，但随后它迅速蔓延，不久便抵达了帝国首都君士坦丁堡。他写道，人们甚至还没反应过来就被疾病缠身。他们开始发烧，身上长出痛苦的肿块，并陷入谵妄甚至昏迷。不久之后，每天都有数百人死亡，接着是数千人，然后是上万人。帝国本身似乎都在动摇根基。普罗科匹厄斯写道，面对这场灾难，除了将之归咎于上帝，根本不可能写出或想出任何其他的解释。汤姆·霍兰德，你在这档节目里总是非常热衷于将各种解释归结于上帝。你认为这是一次神迹，还是觉得背后另有隐情？我觉得背后可能另有隐情。是的。而且我非常高兴地宣布，
that we are joined by someone who also thinks that there was more to it than that? I think there may be more to it. Yeah. And I'm delighted to say that we are joined by someone who also thinks that there was more to it than that, friend of the show, Professor Kyle Harper from the University of Oklahoma. And if you haven't listened already, we did, I thought, a kind of absolutely, for me, eye-opening two-part episode with Kyle on the history of disease. And I'm more thrilled than I can say that we've got him back once again to talk more specifically about the book that he wrote before his book on disease, The Fate of Rome, Climate, Disease, and the End of an Empire. And I read actually on a holiday in Greece, so surrounded by all the evidence for the glories of classical civilization about three or four years ago. And honestly, I've been wanting to have Carl back on as I really enjoyed the previous episode that we did,
我们迎 来了...我觉得背后可能另有隐情。是的。而且我非常高兴地宣布，我们迎来了另一位同样认为背后另有隐情的朋友——来自俄克拉荷马大学的凯尔·哈珀（Kyle Harper）教授。如果您还没听过之前的节目，我们曾和凯尔录制过一期关于疾病史的双集节目，对我来说那绝对是开拓视野的。而现在能请他再次回归，专门来聊聊他在疾病著作《罗马的命运：气候、疾病与一个帝国的终结》（The Fate of Rome: Climate, Disease, and the End of an Empire）之前写的那本书，我激动得无以言表。大约三四年前，我实际上是在希腊度假时读的这本书，当时周围全都是古典文明辉煌成就的见证。说实话，我一直想把凯尔请回来，因为我真的很享受我们之前的节目，
kind of so eye-opening. And it's wonderful to have you back. And today we thought we'd look at the argument that you advance in The Fate of Rome that... Well, you wrote the book. Give us a quick summary of your argument. Well, thank you so much for all that. I'm really honored and thrilled to be here.
那种大开眼界的感觉。你能回来真是太好了。今天我们想探讨你在《罗马的命运》中所提出的观点，那就是……呃，书是你写的。给我们简单总结一下你的观点吧。非常感谢你们说了这么多。能够来到这里我感到十分荣幸和兴奋。
And in 2017, I published this book about the importance of the environment and this chapter of the human history. That's the area that I specialize in studying history of the environment. And by the environment, I mean both the physical climate, so patterns of precipitation, patterns of temperature, as well as the biological environment. So that's just a domain of sort of the past that I think doesn't always get the attention that it deserves. It's an area of the past where also we're learning so much about the experience of ancient civilizations that we just didn't know 10 or 20 years ago. And that's true both on the climate side, where the concerns that we have about human-driven climate change have inspired just this sort of incalculable scientific effort to understand the earth and to understand human impact. You have to understand sort of incalculable scientific effort to understand the earth and to understand human
在 2017 年，我出版了这本关于环境在人类历史这一章节中重要性的书。这是我专门研究的领域——环境史。这里所说的环境，既指自然气候，也就是降水模式、气温模式，同时也指生物环境。这只是过去历史中一个我认为未能得到应有关注的领域。这也是我们对古代文明经历的认知正在不断加深的领域，这些是我们十年前或二十年前根本不知道的。气候方面也是如此，我们对人类驱动的气候变化的担忧，激发了不可估量的科学努力来了解地球和人类的影响。你必须了解这种不可估量的科学努力，以便理解地球并理解人类
impact. You have to understand sort of the natural background and the natural background of the climate isn't one of perfect stability. The climate's always changing for natural reasons and human impacts, which are massive, sort of overlay those natural dynamics. But the need to understand those natural dynamics of the earth system have really unintentionally created a new archive for people like me who are historians. It wasn't created to sort of study Roman history, but it does tell us things that we just didn't know 10 or 20 years ago. And so we're always learning new things about the Romans. But this is this is like a sort of a whole new wing of the library that we just didn't have the ability to walk into before. And now we do. So as a historian, to me, that's really exciting. And it can also be challenging because it's not necessarily how we're trained.
的影响。你必须了解自然背景，而气候的自然背景并不是绝对稳定的。由于自然原因，气候一直在变化，而人类巨大的影响则叠加在这些自然动态之上。但是，理解地球系统这些自然动态的需求，无意间为像我这样的历史学家创造了一个新的档案馆。它不是为了研究罗马历史而创建的，但它确实告诉了我们十到二十年前所不知道的事情。所以我们总是在了解关于罗马人的新知识。但这就像是图书馆里一个我们以前根本无法进入的全新侧翼。而现在我们可以进去了。因此，作为一名历史学家，这让我感到非常兴奋。这同时也可能具有挑战性，因为这不一定是我们受过培训的方向。
And and it's not easy to to integrate natural forces with with human factors but but i think it's fun to try and i think we're still at the beginning of a really exciting period so in a kind of nutshell the argument of the fate of rome is that um the climate and disease played a much greater part in what happens to the roman world you know in uh i don't don't know, the 5th, 6th centuries and so on, than we previously, you know, the old kind of Edward Gibbon decline and fall sort of model, where it's the behavior of emperors, but and also the movements of kind of barbarians and so on, that there's much more to it than that, basically, that and disease in particular, you think plays a really big part in that story.
而且，将自然力量与人类因素结合起来并不容易，但我认为尝试起来很有趣，而且我认为我们仍然处于一个非常令人兴奋的时期的开始。所以，简而言之，《罗马的命运》一书的观点是，呃，在罗马世界发生的事情中，气候和疾病起到了比我们之前认为的要大得多的作用，你知道的，在呃……我不知道，5世纪、6世纪等等时期，相比于以前的那种爱德华·吉本式的“衰亡论”模型——即归咎于皇帝的行为以及蛮族的迁徙等等——其实背后还有更多原因，基本上就是，特别是疾病，你认为在那个故事中扮演了非常重要的角色。
That's right. And I think you still need all the human factors. You need barbarians. You need class tensions between the rich and the poor. You need political dynamics. You need senators and equestrians and Italians and provincials. So you need all of those tensions, internal and external. But I think you can actually understand the story in a more accurate and richer way by realizing that all of those human factors play out in a world that is sort of always fragile, always on the edge. have in modern times. So life expectancy in pre-industrial times, under the best of circumstances, is, you know, around 30. And in the Roman Empire, we think it was probably more like in the mid-20s. So even in times when there's not some devastating pandemic, just the material reality of life is that it's very hard. And as you say, to me, disease is the even more powerful force. These societies are just living on the biological edge. Mortality is always ubiquitous. It's unpredictable in a society where most people, most of the time, die of infectious disease. But these pandemics that the Romans experience, and there's really a series of them in the second, third, and then most importantly, in the sixth century, when the bubonic plague appears. So Carly, you said just then that the average kind of life expectancy in antiquity is 30 years.
确实如此。而且我认为你仍然需要所有的人类因素。你需要蛮族。你需要富人和穷人之间的阶级紧张关系。你需要政治动态。你需要元老、骑士、意大利人和行省居民。所以你需要所有这些内部和外部的张力。但我觉得，如果认识到所有这些人类因素都在一个总是脆弱的、总是处于边缘的世界中展开，你就能以更准确、更丰富的方式理解这个故事。就像现代一样。因此，在前工业化时代，在最佳情况下，预期寿命大约是30岁。而在罗马帝国，我们认为可能更接近20多岁。所以，即使在没有发生毁灭性大流行的时期，生活的物质现实本身也是非常艰难的。正如你所说，对我们来说，疾病是一种更具破坏力的力量。这些社会正生活在生物学的边缘。死亡无处不在。在一个大多数人绝大多数时候死于传染病的社会里，这是不可预测的。但罗马人经历过的大流行，实际上是一系列的大流行，发生在公元2世纪、3世纪，以及最重要的是，在公元6世纪鼠疫出现的时候。凯尔，你刚才说古代的平均预期寿命是30岁。
And then you said under the Roman Empire, it's probably closer to 25, implying that the Roman Empire is actually bad for people's health. And that would, I think, seem kind of counterintuitive to a lot of listeners who would think of the Roman Empire is actually bad for people's health. And that would, I think, seem kind of counterintuitive to a lot of listeners who would think of the Roman Empire, let's say, in its heyday, the Antonine Age, the Golden Age, the age that Edward Gibbon said was the age that most people would say was the happiest in human history, that actually, this golden age of temples and roads and functioning sewerage systems is actually terrible for people's health. The Roman Empire, I argue, is paradoxically bad for people's health. And this is something
然后你又说在罗马帝国时期，这个数字更接近25岁，这意味着罗马帝国实际上对人们的健康有害。我想，这对于许多听客来说似乎有些反直觉，他们会认为罗马帝国对人们的健康是有害的。我想，这对于许多听客来说似乎有些反直觉，他们会认为罗马帝国，比如说在其全盛时期——安东尼时代、黄金时代（爱德华·吉本曾说这是人类历史上大多数人会认为最幸福的时代），实际上，这个充满神庙、道路和完善下水道系统的黄金时代，对人们的健康来说实际上是一场灾难。我認為，罗马帝国悖论般地对人们的健康有害。而这其实是
actually that, first of all, there's a strong comparative basis for this claim that in late pre-industrial times, we know that living in cities, whether it's London or Amsterdam, is very risky for your health. And in the Roman period, there's a similar plausibility to say, look, when you have hundreds of thousands, upwards of a million people with no biomedicine, with limited waste disposal, living in extreme proximity, including with their animals, it just creates the ecology where it's so much easier for infectious diseases. They're kind of sinks, little ones, big ones of disease. There's sinks of disease. There's sinks of human life. A city like Rome would have been a demographic sink that simply
一个……首先，这种说法有着强有力的比较基础：在后来的前工业化时代，我们知道居住在城市里（无论是伦敦还是阿姆斯特丹）对健康是非常有风险的。在罗马时期，也有着类似的合理性：当你有成百上千、甚至多达百万的人口，没有任何生物医学，废物处理有限，极端密集地生活在一起，甚至与动物同住，这就创造了一种生态环境，让传染病极其容易传播。它们就像是疾病的聚宝盆，有大有小。它们是疾病的集散地。它们是人类生命的黑洞。像罗马这样的城市，本就是一个 demographic sink（人口黑洞），
required constant replenishment from migrants. I mean, Rome in its imperial heyday is kind of a million, maybe over a million people. There's never been a city as large. So in terms of the impact on health, humanity as a species is kind of pushing at limits with the urban fabric of Rome. Yeah, that's right. I mean, it's a kind of step forward in the ability of society to provision such a city. And it required both state provision as well as a very highly functioning market to feed that many people. But this is also a common pattern. The ability to create that density wasn't matched by the ability of public health responses to maintain a sanitary and healthy environment. And that doesn't mean that the Romans didn't have any concept of public health or desire
仅仅依靠源源不断的外来移民来补充人口。我的意思是，全盛时期的罗马帝国大约有一百万，甚至可能超过一百万人口。从来没有过这么大的城市。因此，就对健康的影响而言，人类作为一个物种，其罗马的城市结构正在挑战极限。是的，确实如此。我的意思是，这是社会为供应这样一个城市而向前迈出的一步。它既需要国家供给，也需要一个高效运转的市场来养活这么多人。但这也是一个常见的模式。创造这种人口密度的能力，并未与公共卫生应对措施保持卫生和健康环境的能力相匹配。这并不意味着罗马人没有任何公共卫生概念或对公共卫生的渴望，
for public health. I just think they were simply overwhelmed by the density of a city that was bigger than any that had existed and bigger than any that really would exist in Europe until probably the 18th century. Am I right in thinking that Romans actually got shorter? So literally they're shrinking as the empire is expanding and the population is physically shrinking. People get shorter. And so then you have to ask why. There are different factors that go into achieved stature, partly it's genetics, but partly it's environment. The environmental part is affected by nutrition. So a lot of it has to do with how much food in particular, how much protein you're getting during your sort of youth. But a major, major factor is also the infectious disease environment. And so when children are constantly fighting off diarrheal diseases, malaria, it imposes such a heavy burden on the developing body that the body has to, it faces trade-offs.
我只是认为他们完全被一个比以往任何存在过的城市都要大、并且在18世纪之前欧洲可能不会再有任何城市能与之相比的城市的密度给压垮了。我这样想对吗：罗马人的身高实际上变矮了？也就是说，随着帝国的扩张和人口的实际萎缩，他们确实在变矮。人们的身高在缩水。那么你就会问为什么。导致身高增长的因素有很多，部分是基因，但部分也是环境。环境因素受到营养的影响。所以很大程度上取决于你在青少年时期摄入了多少食物，特别是多少蛋白质。但一个极其重要的因素也是传染病环境。因此，当儿童不断与腹泻病、疟疾作斗争时，它给发育中的身体施加了沉重的负担，以至于身体必须面对权衡取舍。
And it can't grow because it's funding the immune system's battle against infectious diseases. And so I think the best explanation is that you have a dense urban civilization and a very interconnected civilization, too. It's not just the cities. It's the fact that they're connected together. And again, we know this from really, really good data from the 18th and 19th century. Like in America, there's a lot of study of very good study of bone links in 18th, 19th century colonial and early United States. And like the people who live in railroad towns are shorter than the people who live in towns of the same size,
它无法生长，因为它要把能量用来资助免疫系统与传染病作斗争。所以我觉得最好的解释是：你拥有一个稠密的城市文明，同时也是一个高度互联的文明。不仅仅是城市。而是它们彼此相连的事实。同样，我们从18世纪和19世纪非常非常好的数据中也知道这一点。比如在美国，有很多关于18世纪、19世纪殖民时期和美国早期骨骼长度的非常好的研究。像住在铁路沿线小镇的人，就比那些距离铁路线20英里、规模相同的镇上的人要矮。这是因为病菌在通过铁路传播。
20 miles off the line. And it's because the germs are coming through. Yeah. And it's the transportation networks that creates the transmission network for infectious disease. The weird thing then is that when we, you know, people,
是的。正是交通网络为传染病创造了传播网络。奇怪的是，当我们……你知道，人们……
people who are not super familiar with Roman history, we look at maps, let's say of the Roman empire. we look at maps, let's say, of the Roman Empire and we see the development classically of roads, roads being the great symbol of kind of civilization. Shipping lanes. Yeah, all those things. And we say, gosh, look at the Romans.
对罗马历史不是很熟悉的人，当我们看着地图，比如说罗马帝国的地图时，我们看着地图，比如说罗马帝国的地图，然后我们看到经典的道路发展，道路成为文明的伟大象征。航运路线。是的，所有这些。然后我们说，天哪，看看罗马人。
Isn't that amazing? They have villas and they have roads and all these things. And they have, as you say, this kind of urban density. But actually, if you're living in that society with those things, what that means is you are subjecting yourself in a way to a kind of experiment are you unprecedented in human history where you're the sort of epicenter of this swirling massive i don't my metaphor has got completely out of control of this sort of massive you know germs coming in from goodness knows where
难道不是很神奇吗？他们有别墅、有道路以及所有这些东西。而且正如你所说，他们有这种城市密度。但实际上，如果你生活在那个拥有这些东西的社会里，那就意味着你正在以某种方式让自己经历人类历史上史无前例的实验，你成为了这个盘旋的、巨大的——我的比喻彻底失控了——这个巨大的、你知道的，从天知道哪里来的病菌的中心，
as traders and merchants and emissaries and envoys and so on. Is that pretty much the situation? Exactly. And I think it would have been both really sort of low level, sort of not notorious respiratory and gastroenteric diseases. So like we shouldn't forget that collectively the burden on human health of a lot of these colds and, you know, respiratory syncytial virus, or all the, the sort of like low level coughs, colds, flus that, that today, you know, we, we just sort of muscle through them. We don't like it, but remember in the ancient world, those would have been more dangerous. There weren't antibiotics. So a lot of the diarrheal diseases, this really blew my mind. I was young then, and I asked a medically informed historian what would have killed most people in the Roman Empire. And it really did. It just blew
伴随着商贾、商人、使节和特使等等的到来。情况大致如此吗？完全正确。而且我认为这既有非常低级别的、并不知名的呼吸道和胃肠道疾病。比如我们不应该忘记，许多这类感冒、呼吸道合胞病毒，或是各种低级别的咳嗽、感冒、流感，对人类健康的总体负担在今天，你知道的，我们只是勉强挺过去。我们不喜欢这样，但请记住在古代，那些会更加危险。当时没有抗生素。所以许多腹泻疾病，这真的让我大开眼界。我当时还年轻，我问了一位懂医学的历史学家，是什么杀死了罗马帝国的大多数人。当时他说“腹泻”时，真的让我
my mind at the time when he said diarrhea. Even today in much of the world, that's one of the leading causes of early death. We're looking at the golden age of the Roman Empire, the Pax Romana, the Antonine Peace, and you've established that we have these great cities, in the case of Rome, on an unprecedented scale, but the other great cities of the empire is Alexandria, Antioch, and so on. These are vast too. They're linked by roads, by shipping lanes, and that this is terribly detrimental for people's health. There's one further factor, which is, of course, that the trade links that are feeding these great cities extend beyond the limits of the empire. And famously, they head southwards into Africa, because that's where the animals that feature in the arenas are coming from. And their trade
大开眼界。即使在今天的世界大部分地区，这也是导致早期死亡的主要原因之一。我们正在审视罗马帝国的黄金时代、罗马和平、安东尼和平，你已经证实我们拥有这些伟大的城市，就罗马而言达到了空前的规模，但帝国的其他伟大城市如亚历山大、安条克等等也是如此。这些城市也非常庞大。它们通过道路、航运路线相连，这对人们的健康造成了极大的损害。还有一个因素，那就是，为这些伟大城市提供食物的贸易路线延伸到了帝国边界之外。众所周知，它们向南延伸到非洲，因为竞技场中出现的动物就是从那里来的。它们的贸易
links are starting to be established along what will become the Silk Roads, you know, in the age of the Antonines, as far as China. And you point out in your book that Central Africa and Central Eurasia are absolute kind of breeding grounds for incredibly lethal diseases. Yeah, I mean, it's just like COVID-19. It's really, you know, mutatus mutandus travels quickly around the world on the jet airplane. They didn't have jets, but they had sailing networks and they had horses. And when you connect different populations, it's just basic ecology of infectious disease. Those populations then have the opportunity to expose each other to the disease pools that they have. So the Romans are probably giving away diseases. They're probably taking their diseases elsewhere, and they're certainly increasingly exposed to the diseases of other populations. But the Roman Empire is kind of unique as the intersection point between these two incredibly dangerous breeding grounds of disease, kind of Central Asia with its various kind of rodents. And then in Africa with all its caves
路线在安东尼时代开始沿着将成为丝绸之路的路线建立，一直延伸到中国。你在书中指出，中非和中亚绝对是极其致命疾病的滋生地。是的，我的意思是，这就像COVID-19一样。真的，你知道，mutatus mutandus（在作出必要改变之后），乘喷气式飞机在全球快速传播。他们当时没有喷气机，但他们有航海网络和马匹。当你把不同的人口连接起来时，这就是传染病的基本生态学。这些人口随后有机会将他们各自拥有的疾病库暴露给彼此。因此罗马人可能在传播疾病，他们可能把自己的疾病带到别处，而且他们肯定越来越多地暴露于其他人口的疾病之中。但罗马帝国作为这两个极其危险的疾病滋生地之间的交汇点，可以说是独一无二的：一个是以各种啮齿动物闻名的中亚，另一个则是到处都是
full of bats and chimpanzees with Ebola and so on. Yeah. I mean, infectious diseases, every disease comes from somewhere. They come from wild animals that the pathogen then adapts to humans either directly, sometimes through the domestic animal. And there are certainly different environmental factors that can create kind of hotspots. One is simply biodiversity in general. There's more animals, there's more diseases, there's more opportunity. But there are some in particular, the presence of primates that are closely related to us. So all of the malarial diseases come from old world primates, from apes in particular, that have bodies and immune systems like ours. And so they're more likely to be the source of new infectious diseases. And as you said, bats, bats and rodents play a really important role, just because there's so many small mammals out there that are that are swapping around their viruses, and creating evolutionary chances to cross to humans. That's certainly what happened with COVID-19. Let's let's go through some of these major sort of crises. So Tom mentioned the Antonines, you know, Gibbon, most of our listeners, well, many of them will know that
满是蝙蝠的洞穴以及带有埃博拉病毒等病原体的黑猩猩的非洲。是的。我的意思是，传染病，每种疾病都有其来源。它们来自野生动物，病原体随后直接适应人类，有时是通过家养动物。确实有不同的环境因素可以产生所谓的“热点地区”。其中之一就是一般的生物多样性。动物更多，疾病更多，机会更多。但其中有一些尤为突出，比如与我们密切相关的灵长类动物的存在。因此，所有的疟疾都来自旧世界灵长类动物，特别是类人猿，它们拥有与我们类似的身和免疫系统。因此，它们更有可能成为新传染病的源头。正如你所说，蝙蝠和啮齿动物发挥了非常重要的作用，仅仅是因为有那么多小型哺乳动物在交换它们的病毒，并创造了跨越到人类身上的进化机会。这肯定就是COVID-19发生的情况。让我们……让我们来看看其中一些主要的危机。所以汤姆提到了安东尼时代，你知道，吉本，我们的绝大多数听众，许多人会知道这一点，
because we've referred to it before that Gibbon famously said this was a great golden age you know when you would have chosen to have lived but before i mean within 100 years or so the empire has plunged into you know it's a tremendous crisis you got the crisis of the third century endless emperors and what you might say is one of the triggers for that is you have one of the first of this succession of plays don't you the antonine plague so do you think that's one of the things that basically pushes the empire of course as it were yeah i mean the antonine plague is a major disease event that starts in the 160s and i think it's it's worth sort of even saying very basically it is a pandemic it meets all the the criteria for being an epidemic that is widespread, which is all that a pandemic
因为我们之前提到过，吉本曾著名地指出这是一个伟大的黄金时代，你知道的，是你愿意选择生活的时代，但在我看来——在大约100年内，帝国便陷入了，你知道的，一场巨大的危机。你迎来了三世纪危机，无休止的皇帝，而你可以说其中一个触发因素就是你迎来了一连串瘟疫中的第一场，不是吗？安东尼瘟疫。所以你认为这是基本上把帝国推向那样的原因之一吗？是的，我的意思是，安东尼瘟疫是一个重大的疾病事件，始于160年代，而且我认为它甚至可以被非常基本地描述为：这是一场大流行病，它符合大流行的所有标准，即传播广泛，这也就是大流行
is. So it's a sudden increase in mortality over a mass spatial area, including all three continents that the Roman Empire touches. If there had been a pandemic, I would say we would know it. I would go so far as to say there wasn't a pandemic for centuries that we can detect. Now, of course, there have been epidemics, and we know that at the city level, regional level, there's always volatility in the death rate. What you have in the 160s is this truly pandemic widespread disease event that is everywhere basically at once.
的全部含义。因此，它是一场在广大地理空间内突然爆发的死亡率激增，包括罗马帝国触及的所有三大洲。如果当时曾有过大流行，我想我们会知道的。我甚至要说，好几个世纪以来我们都没有检测到什么大流行病。当然，曾经有过流行病，我们也知道在城市层面、区域层面，死亡率总是存在波动。你在160年代所经历的是一场真正的大流行、广泛的疾病事件，它基本上同时在各地爆发。
You say probably the single most lethal mortality event in human history up to that time. Yeah, I mean... Seven million people killed. There would have been big epidemics before. There are certainly periods in the Bronze and Iron Age where we don't have the same historical record, but also population levels are lower. So that limits the scope. So I think in the height of the Roman Empire, you have this pandemic event that probably
你说这可能是人类历史上到那时为止单一最具杀伤力的死亡事件。是的，我的意思是……七百万人死亡。之前肯定也发生过大型流行病。青铜时代和铁器时代肯定有一些时期，我们没有同样的歷史记录，但当时的人口水平也较低。这就限制了规模。所以我认为在罗马帝国的鼎盛时期，你经历的这场大流行事件可能
was the biggest, deadliest disease event that maybe ever happened. The first true pandemic, Kyle? Is that too strong? It's the first very well-attested pandemic. Right. And that we can follow its growth because it originates, doesn't it, in Parthia, so in Mesopotamia. Part of the problem with the Antonine Plague is we don't know the the pathogen that cost it which is kind of a an important detail that's out there and we could figure out the the pathogen of the antonine plague in theory but nobody's been able to to find it um but the roman sources say that the troops um started this whole thing when they were inside the the parthian empire and they sacked
是有史以来最大、最致命的疾病事件。第一场真正的大流行吗，凯尔？这样说会太夸张吗？这是第一场有充分文字记载的大流行。没错。而且我们可以追踪它的发展，因为它起源于帕提亚，也就是美索不达米亚，对吧？安东尼瘟疫的问题之一在于，我们不知道导致它的病原体是什么，这是一个悬而未决的重要细节，理论上我们可以弄清楚安东尼瘟疫的病原体，但没有人能够找到它，不过罗马史料记载，军队在进入帕提亚帝国境内并洗劫了
a temple of apollo and it let loose. Bad idea. Always a bad idea. Don't piss off Apollo. Of all the gods. And I think that's kind of a just so story that I think that the troops probably play some role because it breaks out right at that time. But there's an inscription that says that there's a plague the year before that already in Asia Minor. So I think the disease was already there. Well, that's quite COVID, isn't it? an inscription that says the that there's a plague the year before that already in asia minor so i think the disease was already there well that's quite covid isn't it that's what like you know
阿波罗神庙时，引发了这一切。这可不是个好主意。永远都不是好主意。别惹阿波罗。在所有的神明之中。我认为这有点像是一个“事后诸葛亮”的故事，我认为军队可能确实起了某种作用，因为它恰好在那个时候爆发。但有一块铭文显示，早在前一年小亚细亚就已经发生了瘟疫。所以我认为疾病当时已经在那里了。这很像新冠肺炎，对吧？有一块铭文显示小亚细亚在前一年就已经有了瘟疫，所以我认为疾病当时已经存在。这真的很像新冠肺炎，对吧？就像……你知道的，
like people discovering covid in the paris sewers in you know the october before the shoe leather epidemiology and there's there's this really interesting arabian inscription uh in sebaic in the the 150s that says there was a plague that killed everybody in Arabia, like a decade before the Antonine Plague. Of course, we don't know. Was that the same thing? Maybe, maybe not. And then there's these really interesting disease outbreaks in China too. And we need more work that can really cross these very, very different cultural and language boundaries. Because I would love to know if the Chinese pandemics of the mid and late second century are really, really related to the Antonine Plague. I think we'll make progress on that.
就像人们在十月份的巴黎下水道里发现新冠肺炎一样，通过鞋底流行病学（实地流行病学），而且在公元150年代，有一块非常有趣的萨巴伊克语（Sabaic）阿拉伯铭文，上面说有一场瘟疫杀死了阿拉伯半岛上的所有人，就像安东尼瘟疫爆发前十年那样。当然，我们不知道。那是同一回事吗？也许是，也许不是。然后中国也爆发了非常有趣的疫情。我们需要做更多的工作来真正跨越这些非常、非常不同的文化和语言边界。因为我很想知道公元2世纪中叶和晚期的中国大流行是否真的与安东尼瘟疫有关。我认为我们在这方面会取得进展。
But right now it's just sort of out there and we need a lot of work to figure that out. But we don't really know exactly where it came from. Okay, with the Antonine Plague, we've got our first pandemic to hit the Roman Empire. There are more to come. And I think that we should take a break now. And then when we come back, plagues, we've got them.
但现在它只是个未解之谜，我们需要做大量工作才能弄清楚。但我们确实不知道它究竟源自何方。好吧，随着安东尼瘟疫的爆发，我们迎来了袭击罗马帝国的首场大流行。还会有更多。我想我们现在应该休息一下。等我们回来，瘟疫，我们应有尽有。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐之余》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你获取娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料的每周必听节目。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are talking the very jolly subject of plagues, disease and the fate of Rome with Professor Kyle kyle harper so the antonine plague has broken out we think that the troops in mesopotamia and parthia have sacked the temple
如果你想享受无广告收听、独家加更节目以及抢先购买现场门票的特权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。我们正在和凯尔·哈珀教授探讨瘟疫、疾病以及罗马命运这个非常愉快的话题。因此，安东尼瘟疫爆发了，我们认为美索不达米亚和帕提亚的军队误打误撞洗劫了
of apollo by mistake are key in spreading it probably um and what basically happens kyle it sort of travels back west uh presumably comes to these big urbanized centers, and then basically lets rip. Is that basically the story? Yeah, we know that when it gets into the cities, it's very, very deadly and devastating. We really still have a pretty wide bounds about how many people it killed. People have estimated the whole spectrum. People said it killed 2% of the population, which in most years, probably about 3% of the Roman empire would have died. So the crude mortality rate would have been
阿波罗神庙是传播它的关键因素，大概吧……凯尔，基本上发生了什么？它一路向西传播……大概传到了这些高度城市化的中心，然后基本上彻底爆发了。故事大致就是这样吗？是的，我们知道当它进入城市时，它是非常、非常致命且具有毁灭性的。对于它究竟夺去了多少人的生命，我们实际上仍然有相当大的估计区间。人们的估计五花八门。有人说它杀死了2%的人口，而在大多数年份里，罗马帝国大约有3%的人口会死亡。所以粗死亡率大约是
about 3% a year. So just in a normal, healthy year, about 3% of the population died. So the people who've argued that only 2% of the population died in the Antonine plague, I think just don't know anything about historical technology. People have also said, you know, this was like the bubonic plagues. It could have been 25, 30% of the population. And I just, I honestly, I don't think that's true over the whole empire. It may have in the cities. That's sort of consistent with the description we have of some of the urban mortality experience. But I think what's really important is it clearly shocked people. I mean, it was different in virulence and scale than anything within their horizon of experience. I said, Carl, this is NVIDIA's question. And I'm sure it's one that doesn't really have an answer,
每年3%。所以在正常、健康的年份里，大约有3%的人口死亡。因此，那些争辩说在安东尼瘟疫中只有2%的人口死亡的人，我认为他们根本不懂历史人口学。也有人说，你知道，这就像鼠疫一样。死亡率可能占到人口的25%、30%。说实话，我真的不认为整个帝国范围内都是如此。城市里可能确实如此。这与我们所掌握的一些城市死亡率经历的描述是一致的。但我认为真正重要的是，它显然震惊了人们。我的意思是，它的毒性和规模是他们经验视野中的任何事物都无法比拟的。我说，卡尔，这是一个有点像恩维（NVIDIA）的问题——（注：此处原文疑为口误或专有名词误听，暂译）而且我确信这其实没有什么答案，
but the plague hits. And from that point on, essentially, the stability of the empire starts to crumble, and you start to get rival emperors, incredibly a quickening succession rate of emperors. You get wars, civil wars, all kinds of problems. Do you think that the plague is a contributory factor to what's called the crisis of the third century? Or is it just kind of background noise? Yeah, I mean, that is a great question. I'd start by saying that I really separate out the Antonine Plague of the 160s that kind of reverberates a couple of times. It's interesting that whatever it is,
但瘟疫袭来。从那时起，帝国的稳定性基本上开始崩溃，你开始看到敌对的皇帝，皇帝更迭的速度快得不可思议。你遭遇了战争、内战以及各种各样的问题。你认为瘟疫是导致所谓“三世纪危机”的促成因素吗？还是它只是一种背景噪音？是的，这是一个极好的问题。首先我要说的是，我确实把160年代那种反复回响的安东尼瘟疫区分开来。有趣的是，无论它是什么，
it seems to relapse two or three times, and then it kind of seems to go away. And so I actually think there's a there's this moment where there is a short term crisis and it does fundamentally change the direction of Roman history because up to that point, the population is growing. And as best we can tell, the economy is still growing. So I don't see this as a kind of endogenous crisis that was inevitable, that it really, to explain it, you have to have the pathogen coming and causing a shock to the system. So I kind of separate the second century crisis, as important as it is, to say that what emerges on the other side is still pretty recognizable as the kind of Roman Empire of Augustus. The third century crisis is really different.
它似乎复发了两到三次，然后似乎就消失了。所以我实际上认为，在某个时刻，存在着一场短期危机，它从根本上改变了罗马历史的发展方向，因为在那之前，人口在增长。据我们所知，经济仍在增长。因此，我不认为这是一种不可避免的内生性危机，要解释它，必须有病原体的到来并对系统造成冲击。因此，我将公元二世纪的危机隔离开来，尽管它很重要，但可以说，危机过后呈现出的面貌依然很像奥古斯都时期的罗马帝国。三世纪的危机则截然不同。
What comes out on the other side of this generation that goes from about 250 to 275 is a very different, very structurally different empire. And I think the plague that happens in that generation, which is called the Plague of Cyprian, is a contributory factor, not just a background factor. So this plague is much, it's not as well known as the Antonine Plague. It's much more visible kind of in the sources. And yet, and I've never really computed it until I read your account of it. It sounds horrendous.
在经历大约从250年到275年这一代人之后，浮现出的帝国在结构上大不相同。我认为在这一代人中发生的瘟疫，被称为西普里安瘟疫，是一个促成因素，而不仅仅是背景因素。因此，这场瘟疫比安东尼瘟疫更甚，它虽然不那么知名，但在史料中却明显得多。然而——直到我读到你对它的描述之前，我从未真正计算过——听起来太可怕了。
So you say that it might have been a filovirus whose most notorious representative is the Ebola virus. Yeah, I mean, that's terrifying. Ebola is, I i mean it's kind of so lethal that it burns itself out so if if you've got kind of ebola spreading equivalent of ebola spreading through carthage and roman i mean i say carthage because that's where cyprian the bishop of carthage was right i mean that's terrifying right it lasts decades yeah it's, whatever it is, it's clearly deadly and terrifying. And it is, this is a plague that's interesting because it's sort of, people had forgotten about it. I mean, and the major syntheses about the third century crisis that were written in the early 20th century, early 21st century, don't even mention it. I mean, it falls out of the discussion completely. And I think that's obviously unsupportable. But the 250s to 270s, those are a dark period of Roman history. So
所以你说它可能是一种丝状病毒，其最著名的代表就是埃博拉病毒。是的，我的意思是，这太可怕了。埃博拉病毒太致命了，以至于它会自行消亡，所以如果这种相当于埃博拉的病毒在迦太基和罗马蔓延开来——我之所以提到迦太基，是因为迦太基主教西普里安就在那里——我的意思是，这太可怕了，对吧？它持续了几十年。是的，不管它是什么，它显然是致命且可怕的。而且，这场瘟疫很有意思，因为人们几乎把它遗忘了。我是说，20世纪初和21世纪初关于三世纪危机的主要综合研究甚至都没有提到它。我的意思是，它完全从讨论中消失了。我认为这显然是站不住脚的。但从250年代到270年代，那是罗马历史上的一个黑暗时期。所以
unlike the earlier empire, where you always kind of have a solid thread of narratives, there are places in the 250s and 260s where we're not really sure what's happening. Right. And that's what we also get with coming on later to the Justinianic plague, is you do get the sense that sources drop off a cliff. And so maybe that's a kind of measure of how bad a pandemic is, that there just aren't people around to sit and write histories anymore. Yeah. I mean, it's crude and hard to know. I really feel that's a big explanation for what happens in parts of the sixth century, like where Italy other sources that should be mentioning it. It's just that there's so little written evidence for that particular moment that may actually, of course, be a reflection of the fact that so many people died. But we don't know if that's the cause. And certainly in the middle of the 250s, 260s, it's a multifaceted crisis. The monetary system
与早期的帝国不同，那时你总能找到一条坚实的叙事线索，但在250年代和260年代的某些地方，我们并不真正清楚发生了什么。确实如此。这也是我们在后来谈到查士丁尼瘟疫时所看到的情况，你会感觉到史料断崖式下跌。所以这或许也是衡量一场大流行病严重程度的一种标准，那就是已经没有人能够坐在那里写历史了。是的。我的意思是，这很粗糙，很难确切了解。我真的觉得这是对六世纪某些时期发生的事情的一个重大解释，比如在意大利，本该提到它的其他史料却没有了。只是那个特定时期的文字记录太少了，这当然可能反映了这样一个事实：太多人死亡了。但我们不知道这是否是原因。当然，在250年代和260年代中期，这是一场多重危机。货币系统
falls apart. I mean, the silver, for all intents and purposes, disappears from the coinage. The imperial center sort of is overtaken by centrifugal forces and nobody knows who the rightful emperor is. There are rivals in the East and in Gaul. There's such a constant succession of emperors that there's, on average, about one a year for a generation. So there's political turmoil within the empire. And then there's clearly a new level of threat beyond. So this is when the Persian, Achaemenid dynasty, Neo-Persian dynasty comes into power. And they're far more expansionist than the Parthian dynasty that they succeeded, that creates a greater challenge on the eastern
崩溃了。我的意思是，白银实际上从铸币中消失了。帝国中心某种程度上被离心力所吞没，没有人知道谁是合法的皇帝。东方和高卢都出现了竞争对手。皇帝更迭如此频繁，以至于在这一代人中，平均大约一年换一个。因此，帝国内部存在政治动荡。此外，外部显然也出现了新的威胁水平。这时，波斯阿契美尼德王朝、新波斯王朝掌权了。他们比他们所取代的帕提亚王朝更具扩张性，这在东部边境构成了更大的挑战，
frontier, which had always been Rome's probably most challenging frontier. And then on the northern frontier, at the same time, you have larger and larger confederations of northern, probably mostly Germanic people groups that are more formidable and start to cross into the empire. This had really started with Marcus Aurelius, but in the 250s, the Goths come in. Is it coincidence that all these crises are reaching the boil at the same time as this terrible plague is sweeping the Mediterranean? Or is there a degree of cause and effect there? Yeah. One of the really interesting questions is, is there cause and effect, but also which way is the cause and effect? Because human health is fragile. And if you start to see a breakdown of systems of food
而东部边境历来可能是罗马最具挑战性的边境。与此同时，在北部边境，你看到了越来越庞大的北方人群联合体，他们可能主要是日耳曼人，战斗力更强，并开始侵入帝国。这实际上是从马可·奥勒留时期开始的，但在250年代，哥特人入侵了。所有这些危机都在这场可怕的瘟疫席卷地中海的同时达到沸点，这仅仅是巧合吗？还是其中存在着某种因果关系？是的。真正有趣的问题之一是，是否存在因果关系，以及因果关系的方向是怎样的？因为人类的健康是脆弱的。如果你开始看到粮食供应系统崩溃，
provisioning, for instance, so you have this very complex society that is dependent on, you know, what we would call just-in-time delivery. There's not, you know, two, three years of food stored up that you can eat. And so if you do have a, all of a sudden you have invasion and imperial civil war, that means that the harvest don't come in and the food shipments can't make it. Then you have people that are hungry and when people are really, that are already poor, move into starvation level hunger. I mean, we know this for instance, from the 1840s in the Irish potato famine. You have a poor society where the potato harvest fails dismally. And most people don't actually die of starvation. They die of infectious disease. They
例如，你拥有这样一个极其复杂的社会，它依赖于我们所说的即时配送。没有储备两三年的食物供你食用。因此，如果你突然遭遇入侵和帝国内战，这意味着丰收无法运到，粮食运输无法送达。然后你就会有人挨饿，当那些本来就很贫困的人陷入饥饿的边缘时——我们从1840年代的爱尔兰大饥荒中了解这一点。你有一个贫穷的社会，那里的马铃薯歉收。大多数人实际上并不是死于饥饿，而是死于传染病。他们
have typhus, typhoid, relapsing fever, and so on. So it may be that the pandemic of infectious disease in the third century could be an effect rather than a cause of the crisis, that it just sinks human nutrition and health. But it could be the other way around too. It could be that you have a system where there's already some kind of political tension and it just can't handle it. So it could be, again, a new pathogen that is introduced into a system that's already got some kind of fragility and that that is what tips it beyond a point where it can really still function as a system. So you have the crisis of the third century, but I mean, Rome is still reasonably resilient, right? Because I mean, the empire
患有斑疹伤寒、伤寒、回归热等等。因此，三世纪的传染病大流行可能是危机的结果，而不是原因，它只是摧毁了人类的营养和健康。但情况也可能是反过来的。可能某个系统中已经存在某种政治紧张局势，而它无法应对。因此，它也可能是一种新病原体被引入到一个已经存在某种脆弱性的系统中，正是这一点打破了平衡，使其无法再作为系统正常运转。所以你有三世纪的危机，但我的意思是，罗马仍然相当具有韧性，对吧？因为我的意思是，帝国
doesn't completely fall apart at that point, but it's different. So the system that emerges after this crisis, I mean, you were talking about being recognizable as the Rome of Augustus. This is clearly not the Rome of Augustus, right? By the time you've got to the fourth century or so. Yeah. I mean, I think the Roman empire really could have fallen in the 260s and 270s. And maybe we should frame it instead as sort of saying, how the heck did it not just come apart? Because this is what happens. Empires fall apart, they change, they fragment. Then eventually, hundreds of years later, somebody puts it back together again. But that's not what happens. Actually, what happens in 268, this is really the revolutionary year. You have a Danubian
那时并没有完全土崩瓦解，但确实变得不一样了。所以在这场危机之后浮现出的系统，我的意思是，你刚才提到它还能被认出是奥古斯都时期的罗马。但到了四世纪左右，这显然已经不再是奥古斯都的罗马了，对吧？是的。我的意思是，我认为罗马帝国在公元260年代和270年代确实本可能已经灭亡。也许我们应该换个角度来看，比如想想：它到底是怎么做到没有彻底四分五裂的？因为这就是常有的事。帝国会土崩瓦解、发生变化、走向分裂。然后最终在几百年后，又有人把它重新拼凑起来。但事情并没有那样发展。实际上，在公元268年，这才是真正的革命性一年。你有一个多瑙河流域的
cavalry officer named Claudius who takes over the empire and starts paying donatives to his military officers in gold. That's it. The next 300 years of Roman history is Danubian military officers running the show and paying their officer class a lot of gold. And that is not the Augustan system. The Augustan system is rich senators from the Mediterranean who are mostly civilian, who are kind of gentlemen officers that command these massive armies with sort of experienced officers by their side. You have a coup in the 260s and 270s, and the empire from that point forward is ruled almost entirely, there's an important exception or two like the Theodosian dynasty, but is almost entirely, there's an important exception or two, like the Theodosian dynasty, but is almost entirely ruled by experienced military commanders and their offspring, who come from a tiny, tiny part of the empire that is very much not the posh Italian Senate.
骑兵军官名叫克劳狄乌斯，他接管了帝国，并开始用黄金向他的军事军官支付赏金。就是这样。罗马历史接下来的300年，都是多瑙河流域的军事军官在掌控局面，并给他们的军官阶层发放大量的黄金。这已经不是奥古斯都的系统了。奥古斯都的系统是由来自地中海的富裕参议员组成的，他们大多是文职人员，有点像绅士军官，身旁带着经验丰富的军官去指挥这些庞大的军队。你在260年代和270年代经历了一场政变，从那时起，帝国的统治几乎完全——虽然有一两个重要的例外，比如狄奥多西王朝——几乎完全由经验丰富的军事指挥官及其后代统治。他们来自帝国一个极其微小的角落，那绝不是高档的意大利参议院。
So these are the kind of guys who would cheerfully introduce a vaccine passport, or something like that. You are getting a kind of apparatus of military control that had not existed previously. And through the fourth century, this enables the Roman Empire to, it has a very, very heavy tread. Then in the fifth century, it all starts to crumble in the West. And the figure who is associated with that collapse is Attila, the king of the Huns. And you describe the Huns, intriguingly, as armed climate refugees on horseback, which is not how they are traditionally thought of. So what's going on there that makes you say that?
所以这些家伙就是那种会兴高采烈地推出疫苗护照之类东西的人。你正在见证一种此前并不存在的军事控制机器。在整个四世纪里，这使得罗马帝国能够——它的步伐非常非常沉重。然后在五世纪，西方的一切开始崩溃。与这种崩溃联系在一起的人物是匈人国王阿提拉。你引人入胜地将匈人描述为“骑马的武装气候难民”，这并不是传统上对他们的看法。那么，到底发生了什么让你这么说？
Did I say that? Oh, my gosh. You did. It's a good line. Don't be ashamed of it. There's endless um debate that will never end and hopefully never ends because it keeps us employed um and also causes a lot of a lot of fun jolly uh academic argument about whether the the movements both of germanic peoples but also of central asian peoples like the huns Huns in the fourth and fifth century really are movements of people or whether what we're seeing are sort of changing cultural organizations and terms and names that really we shouldn't imagine as sort of a massive migration of people. I would still stick by the basic importance of understanding environmental stress as a motivator for human movement and actual human mobility is a major factor. that they carry disease and obviously sometimes mass migration does bring disease did the goths so on the huns whatever did they bring disease from central asia into the roman world yeah it's
我这么说过吗？哦，天哪。你确实说过。这是一句好台词。别为此感到害羞。会有无穷无尽的辩论，永远不会结束，也希望永远不要结束，因为这不仅能让我们保持就业，还引发了许多充满乐趣、愉快而又热烈的学术争论：无论是日耳曼民族的迁徙，还是四、五世纪像匈人这样中亚民族的迁徙，究竟真的是人口的迁徙，还是我们所看到的只是一些不断变化的文化组织、术语和名称，实际上我们不应该把它们想象成大规模的人口迁移。我仍然坚持认为，理解环境压力作为人类移动的催化剂具有根本性的重要性，而且实际的人口流动是一个主要因素。他们携带疾病，显然有时大规模迁移确实会带来疾病。哥特人、匈人等等，他们到底有没有把疾病从中亚带入罗马世界？是的，这
a great question and there was a there was an article that was published um just this last year a couple months ago by um sabina hoytner on the plague of cyprian that suggests that i don't know that i totally agree, but I like putting this idea into the discussion that actually the plague of Cyprian may have come from either Eastern Europe or somewhere beyond as the Goths moved into the empire. And there certainly is a correlation that makes that a plausible story. One thing we don't actually have like really directly in the fourth and fifth century is any very strong evidence for disease moving with people from Central Asia. And actually, this is kind of a problem because maybe we'll come back to this when we talk more about the
是个好问题。去年，也就是几个月前，萨宾娜·霍特纳发表了一篇文章，探讨了西普里安瘟疫，文章暗示——我不知道我是否完全同意，但我喜欢把这个观点引入讨论——实际上西普里安瘟疫可能是随着哥特人迁入帝国而从东欧或更远的地方传来的。而且确实存在某种相关性，使得这成为一个貌似合理的说法。我们在四、五世纪并没有直接掌握的最重要的一点证据，是关于疾病随中亚人口移动而传播的任何非常强有力的证据。实际上，这有点像个问题，因为也许当我们更多地讨论
Justinianic plague. One of the really big questions right now is how does it get from Central Asia to the Mediterranean? And actually, the easiest answer would be across the steppe. That's how the Black Death seems to move from Central Asia to the West in the 14th century or even 13th century. But we don't actually have very good evidence for this. And so I tend to sort of think that the written record is good enough that if the plague was coming with the migrants in the 4th and 5th century, we would know it. But we have to say that's an open question. So Kyle, the 6th century, 541, this terrible plague is reported in Pelusium and then spreading to Alexandria in Egypt and then to Constantinople and then basically across the Mediterranean world.
查士丁尼瘟疫时，我们会回过头来谈论这一点。目前真正的大问题之一是：它是如何从中亚传到地中海的？实际上，最简单的答案是通过欧亚大草原。14世纪甚至13世纪时，黑死病似乎就是这样从中亚传到西方的。但我们实际上并没有这方面的很好证据。所以我倾向于认为，文字记录已经足够详细，如果瘟疫是在4世纪和5世纪随着移民一起到来的，我们理应会知道。但这仍然是一个开放的问题。那么，凯尔，6世纪，即公元541年，这场可怕的瘟疫据报道首先出现在培琉喜阿姆，然后蔓延到埃及的亚历山大，接着到君士坦丁堡，最后基本传遍了整个地中海世界。
And we know now that it was definitely plague, right? Yes. So this is a huge, huge deal. We know it's Yersinia pestis. And you say when Yersinia pestis reached the Roman empire, it found an urbanized, interconnected society teeming with rats. Not good news. Not good news. I mean, where to even start? So the plague, bubonic plague, the bacterial disease caused by Yersinia pestis, is the most explosive disease in human history. There's just nothing like it.
我们现在知道那绝对是鼠疫，对吧？是的。所以这是一件极其重大、影响深远的事。我们知道那是鼠疫耶尔森菌。你说过，当鼠疫耶尔森菌抵达罗马帝国时，它面对的是一个城市化、高度互联且老鼠肆虐的社会。这不是什么好消息。这不是好消息。我的意思是，这该从何说起呢？所以鼠疫，也就是由鼠疫耶尔森菌引起的细菌性疾病，是人类历史上最具爆发力的疾病。根本没有什么能与之相比。
Because we're kind of collateral damage, aren't we? I mean, basically it's a disease of rodents. And that's why it's so deadly. Because it doesn't care. It doesn't have to worry about it. Its evolution doesn't depend on us at all. It's a rodent disease from start to finish. It lives permanently in colonies of burrowing rodents here in America, in prairie dog populations, most ancestrally in Central Asia, in gerbils and marmots and gerboas and similar kinds of social rodents.
因为我们算是城门失火殃及池鱼的无辜受害者，对吧？我的意思是，它本质上是一种啮齿动物的疾病。这就是为什么它如此致命。因为它根本不在乎我们。它不需要为此操心。它的进化与我们完全没有关系。从头到尾，它都是一种啮齿动物的疾病。它永久寄生在美洲的穴居啮齿动物群落中，比如草原犬鼠种群，而在远古祖先层面则主要寄生在中亚的沙鼠、旱獭、跳鼠以及类似的社会性啮齿动物中。
And when it reaches the Roman Empire, it reaches a world with cities, with armies, with a lot of movement of grain on ships and overland. And wherever you have that, you have black rats, ratus ratus, which is very susceptible to the plague. And there's still a lot we don't totally know, but I think that this is the best version of the story is that the big plague pandemics are really fundamentally dependent on that network of black rats. So you have to think of the humans as sort of this, as you call it, collateral damage, this top level. What's really going on is this panzootic, this major mass scale animal plague that ultimately engulfs us. When the black rats die, their fleas are
当它到达罗马帝国时，它进入了一个拥有城市、军队，且粮食通过船舶和陆路大量运输的世界。无论你在哪里看到这些，你都会看到黑鼠（Rattus rattus），它们对鼠疫非常敏感。虽然还有很多我们并不完全清楚的地方，但我认为这个故事最好的版本是：大瘟疫的流行从根本上依赖于黑鼠的那个网络。所以你必须把人类看作是这种——正如你所说——无辜的受害者，处于最顶层的群体。真正发生的事情是这场泛动物流行病，一场最终将我们吞噬的重大动物瘟疫规模事件。当黑鼠死后，它们的跳蚤就
carrying the bacterium. And this is one of the things that makes plague, plague biologically speaking, it's evolutionary history. It is very, very good at using the flea vector. It builds a biofilm in the digestive tract of the fleas that allows the bacteria to just sort of stack up in the front of the digestive tract and makes the flea simultaneously feel like it's starving. So they're constantly biting and just ejecting bacteria into the next victim. So they're very, very well adapted to the flea vector. And so when the black rats die, these fleas that are infected with the bacteria jump to humans and infect humans with bubonic plague. And how far does it spread? Does it spread to Britain, to Scandinavia,
携带了这种细菌。正是这一点让鼠疫在生物学意义上成为鼠疫，也就是它的进化史。它非常非常善于利用跳蚤作为媒介。它会在跳蚤的消化道中形成一层生物膜，让细菌在消化道前段堆积起来，同时让跳蚤产生一种正在挨饿的错觉。所以它们会不断叮咬，并把细菌注入下一个受害者体内。因此它们对跳蚤媒介的适应能力非常强。所以当黑鼠死后，这些感染了细菌的跳蚤就会跳到人类身上，并让人类感染腺鼠疫。它究竟传播了多远？它传播到英国、斯堪的纳维亚了吗？
you know, to the sort of Germanic areas of Europe and so on? This is one of the really exciting questions where we're learning. We know things that we didn't know in 2017 or 2016 when I was really writing, that the literary sources only go so far. And the literary sources we have all speak with one voice that this was apocalyptic. You read Procopius. And sometimes, of course, we, you know, you have to know what to make of that, what's motivating them, what's their, you know, what do they really
你知道，比如欧洲的日耳曼地区等等？这是一个非常令人兴奋的问题，我们正从中不断了解新知。我们现在知道了一些在2017年或2016年我真正写作时所不知道的事情，那就是文字史料的作用是有限的。我们拥有的文字史料众口一词地认为这是末日般的灾难。你读普罗科皮乌斯的作品。当然，有时你会（你知道的）必须弄清楚该如何看待这一点，是什么在驱使他们，他们的动机是什么，他们真正
know? And, you know, how does Procopius know how many people a day are dying? What does a number mean to Procopius? All of those good questions we can ask of literary sources. But even so, you can only ask questions of literary sources where you have them. And I said there's only one in Italy. There's very little written evidence for Gaul in the 540s. And so what do you make of it when you have one source that is a chronicle that is one line and says there was a magna mortalitas in Italy. What do you make of it? You have to know, did it really reach Italy? Did it really just hit Rome?
知道些什么？而且，普罗科皮乌斯怎么会知道每天有多少人死去？这个数字对普罗科皮乌斯来说意味着什么？所有这些好问题，我们都可以向文字史料提出。但即便如此，你也只能向那些拥有文字史料的地区提问。我说过意大利只有一个。对于540年代的高卢，几乎没有什么书面证据。所以，当你只有一个简短的编年史记录，里面只有一行字说意大利发生了“一场大瘟疫（magna mortalitas）”时，你会作何感想？你必须弄清楚，它真的传到意大利了吗？它真的只是袭击了罗马吗？
Did it get into the other towns? Did it get into the countryside? And this is where the DNA evidence is really starting to help us because it can fill in those blank gaps. If we can find sixth century skeletons that may have died in this pandemic, then it's possible to try and extract the DNA of the pathogen. And so the DNA evidence tells us lots of things, but one of the things that can help us understand is the reach of the pandemic. And so there's a lot we still don't know,
它进入其他城镇了吗？它进入乡村了吗？这就是DNA证据真正开始帮助我们的时候，因为它可以填补那些空白。如果我们能找到可能死于这场大流行病的六世纪骨骼，就有可能尝试提取病原体的DNA。因此，DNA证据告诉了我们很多事情，其中一件可以帮助我们理解的事情就是大流行病的波及范围。所以，依然有很多我们不知道的事，
but we know that the pandemic reached Bavaria, reached tiny little villages, sort of near what's now Munich. We know that it reached, that it reached Britain. And this is the importance of the, the discovery of the DNA at Edix Hill in Cambridgeshire. This is, this is not, you know, the crossroads of civilization, you know, with due respect to. Wow. You're not coming back on this. If it made it to this Hamlet of a hundred, 150 people off the main busy roads, then we really have to ask, you know, where did it not, where could it not have gotten to? I mean,
但我们知道这场大流行病传到了巴伐利亚，传到了靠近现在慕尼黑的那些小村庄。我们知道它传到了英国。这就是在剑桥郡埃迪克斯希尔（Edix Hill）发现DNA的重要性所在。这可不是什么文明的十字路口（恕我直言，对……）。哇。你可别收回这话。如果它连这个只有一百到一百五十人、远离主干道的小村庄都到达了，那我们真的不得不问：它到底能去到哪里去不了的地方？我的意思是，
and we'll learn more with more data, but that's already very, very suggestive that this thing got a lot of places. There is a kind of ongoing debate right now, isn't there, about how serious it was. And there does seem to be a kind of reluctance on the part of many historians to admit that, you know, apocalyptic events can really have an impact on history. My old tutor is a contributor to this debate, Tom. Peter Sarris. Peter Sarris, yes. He's just written a really excellent, I thought,
随着更多数据的出现，我们会学到更多，但这已经非常非常具有暗示性，说明这东西去了很多地方。目前关于它到底有多严重，存在着一场持续的争论，不是吗？许多历史学家似乎有一种不愿承认的态度，即“末日般的事件确实会对历史产生影响”。我的老导师就是这场争论的参与者，汤姆。彼得·萨里斯。彼得·萨里斯，是的。他刚刚写了一篇非常出色的文章，我认为，
kind of breakdown of where things stand. And he's very much on the, it was horrible side of the argument. Yeah, no, no. And Peter, of course, is totally right. But no, his intervention was useful and helpful. And he was onto this very early on. I mean, he knew the plague was a big deal when knowing the plague was a big deal wasn't cool 20 years ago.
对目前的局势进行了剖析。他非常坚定地站在“这极其可怕”的论点这一边。是的，没错。而且彼得当然完全是对的。不过说真的，他的介入是有用且有帮助的。而且他很早就关注到这一点了。我的意思是，当20年前认为鼠疫是一件大事还不够酷的时候，他就知道鼠疫是一件大事了。
And he's a participant in these conversations. And there's a huge range of opinion. To me, there's still so much we don't know, and there is room for debate. I don't think that, that it's particularly fruitful to, to sort of just be so skeptical that, um, that you deny the significance of the plague. I think there's a lot we don't know, but the really interesting and incredible range of opinion is sort of like, was this really bad? Meaning it really did hit the cities in the East and sort of may have trickled over and hit some places in the West, but it wasn't black death-like and the population could kind of rebound from this, but still was a major widespread disease event
而且他是这些对话的参与者。各种观点存在着巨大的差异。对我来说，仍然有太多我们不知道的事情，而且还有讨论的空间。我不认为那种极度怀疑到甚至去否定鼠疫重要性的做法会特别有成效。我认为有很多我们不知道的事情，但那些有趣且令人难以置信的观点差异就像是：这真的很糟糕吗？这意味着它确实袭击了东方的城市，并且可能已经蔓延并袭击了西方的一些地方，但它并没有达到黑死病的程度，人口还可以从中恢复，不过它仍然是一场影响深远的大规模疾病事件；
to this was black death-like and it eliminated some serious part of the population, not just in the towns, but in the countryside, not just in the east, but in the west. Well, Kyle, can I just ask? So a massive, you know, the Dark Age in Britain, when the Romans leave, and then the emergence of Anglo-Saxon kingdoms. And there is this kind of 200-year period where we basically have no idea really what's going on. And somehow in that period, an entirely new language comes to be spoken, new social structures and everything. Do you think, I mean, is it possible that the plague is a contributor to that very mysterious process, do you think? I absolutely think so. I mean, I think it is a factor. Of course, it's not the only factor, but it's actually hard to explain such a dramatic structural change without a major demographic right
演变到这种观点：这就像黑死病一样，它消灭了相当一部分人口，不仅在城镇中，也在乡村中，不仅在东方，也在西方。好了，凯尔，我可以问一下吗？比如英国黑暗时代的巨大动荡，当罗马人离开，然后盎格鲁-·撒克逊王国崛起。有这样一个大约200年的时期，我们基本上完全不知道到底发生了什么。不知何故，在那个时期，一种全新语言开始被说起，新的社会结构等等一切都出现了。你认为——我的意思是，鼠疫有没有可能是促成这个非常神秘的过程的一个因素呢？我绝对这么认为。我的意思是，我认为这是一个因素。当然，这并不是唯一的因素，但实际上，如果没有一场重大的人口结构性
shock being a part of it and i i'll say this too i don't think it's just the plague of justinian in the the first wave of the 540s just as the black death its significance is not just one huge wave of disease it's that the plague then sticks around and the first wave after wave after wave. Yeah, it's it's there for 200 years. And we still have a lot genuinely to learn about the patterns of its recurrence. But in the late Middle Ages, what's so significant is the plague. Boom, it hits. And then a little over 10 years later, it hits again.
冲击作为其中的一部分，很难解释如此戏剧性的结构性变化。而且我要补充一点：我不认为这仅仅是540年代第一波浪潮中的查士丁尼瘟疫。就像黑死病的意义不只是单一的巨大疾病浪潮一样，鼠疫随后留存了下来，一波又一波地卷土重来。是的，它在那里存在了200年。对于它复发的模式，我们仍然有很多真正需要了解的地方。但在中世纪晚期，最引人注目的是鼠疫。轰的一声，它袭来了。然后仅仅十多年后，它又袭来了。
10 years later, it hits again. 10 years later, it hits again. And it's that repeated, it's that change to the whole environment of disease that in the long run is so devastating. You said at the beginning about the seismic effect of the Justinianic plague. So, I mean, politically, the regime in Constantinople is still the same regime. But how long does it take for the kind of political consequences to play out?
十年后，它又袭来了。十年后，它又袭来了。正是这种重复发生、对整个疾病环境的这种改变，从长远来看才是如此具有毁灭性的。你刚才在开头提到了查士丁尼瘟疫的震撼效应。所以，我的意思是，从政治上讲，君士坦丁堡的政权依然是那个政权。但这种政治后果需要多久才会显现出来？
Because obviously a generation after Justinian, I guess you'd say, the Eastern Roman Empire starts to go through these colossal sort of shocks, doesn't it? I mean, even before Justinian's dead, the Downing Frontier is starting to give way, isn't it? I mean, he's just done his kind of reconquista, hasn't he? His attempted reconquista. And then there's a great loss of momentum.
因为很明显，在查士丁尼之后的整整一代人时间里，我想你会这么说，东罗马帝国开始经历这些巨大的某种冲击，不是吗？我的意思是，甚至在查士丁尼死之前，多瑙河边境就开始崩溃了，不是吗？我的意思是，他刚刚完成了他的那种“光复运动（reconquista）”，不是吗？他尝试的光复运动。然后就出现了巨大的动能损失。
And then later on, you have sort of coups and enormous sort of ructions within the empire. So do you think this is politically a massive watershed? And is the plague part of that in creating a sort of, I don't know, in destroying the tax base or creating a sense of apocalyptic fear or what? Yeah, I mean, all of that. But I do think that the plague is a huge part of it. And it's sometimes easy for us with hindsight to say, well, Justinian's campaigns of reconquest were this crazy, completely unrealistic and unattainable dream that caused overstretch. And certainly, it would have stressed the fiscal and military resources of the empire. But I mean, for one
然后到了后来，帝国内部又发生了政变和巨大的动荡。所以你认为从政治上讲这是一个巨大的分水岭吗？鼠疫是否也是其中的一部分，比如它摧毁了税基，或者制造了一种末日恐惧感，又或者是别的什么？是的，我的意思是，所有这些都有。但我确实认为鼠疫是其中非常巨大的一部分。有时我们事后诸葛亮，很容易说：嗯，查士丁尼的光复运动是一个疯狂的、完全不切实际且无法实现的梦想，导致了过度扩张。当然，这确实会给帝国的财政和军事资源带来压力。但我的意思是，一方面，
thing, it doesn't completely fail. I mean, they hold on to North Africa for several generations. Yeah, and Rome. But it does ultimately, I think, have very serious geopolitical consequences, as you mentioned, on the Danube frontier or Italy, where they're in the process of taking back Italy. And there's no reason why they shouldn't have been able to seize all of Italy. They are very successful in getting rid of the Goths. But look at what happens to Italy. It's not Justinian isn't able to hold on to Italy, but it's not like the Goths sort of fight back. It's that ultimately Italy is taken by a completely new people. The Lombards who come in in the five sixties were told very directly by a very well-informed contemporary source
它并没有完全失败。我的意思是，他们对北非的控制维持了好几代人。是的，还有罗马。但最终，我认为它确实带来了非常严重的政治地缘后果，正如你所提到的，在多瑙河边境或意大利，他们正处于夺回意大利的过程中。而且没有理由说他们本不应该能够占领整个意大利。他们在消灭哥特人方面非常成功。但看看意大利发生了什么。并不是查士丁尼无法守住意大利，而是哥特人并没有发起反击。最终，意大利是被一个全新的民族攻占了。560年代入侵的伦巴第人，从一个消息极其灵通的当代信源那里得到了非常直接的告知，
that the plague struck again in five 65 and was so desolating and so powerful and depopulating that by the time the Lombards arrived, there was almost no resistance. call it Byzantine control under Justinian of Italy to the arrival of the Lombards and the complete reconfiguration of power so that the Eastern Roman Empire can only control Rome and Ravenna and sort of the immediate hinterlands of those areas. So how do we explain that? I think you need plague to be a part of the story. And looking even further ahead, of course, Calamity also hits the Roman Empire in the east with Arab invasions and the emergence of what will become an Islamic order. The Quran is a text that seems shot through with apocalyptic anxieties. Do you think that it's
鼠疫在565年再次爆发，其毁灭性、威力和对人口的杀伤力是如此巨大，以至于当伦巴第人抵达时，几乎没有遇到什么抵抗。你可以从查士丁尼对意大利的拜占庭控制，直接过渡到伦巴第人的到来以及权力的完全重组，以至于东罗马帝国只能控制罗马和拉文纳以及这些地区周边的腹地。那么我们该如何解释这一点呢？我认为你需要将鼠疫视为这个故事的一部分。再把目光放得更远一些，当然，随着阿拉伯人的入侵以及将成为伊斯兰秩序的崛起，灾难也降临到了东方的罗马帝国。《古兰经》这部文本似乎充满了末日焦虑。你认为，
possible to see the emergence of Islam against this background of plague as well? Was that pushing it too far? I do. And I think in a couple of ways, this really fits with the story of Islam as part of late antiquity that has been so richly developed by people, by scholars who are not interested in the plague, but it really helped us see that one, Islam is a late antique religion. So it doesn't come from sort of outside the cultural worlds that we think of when we think of late antiquity, that this, that the, that Arabia, the Red Sea world really is deeply economically and culturally and politically connected to the world of the Eastern Romans and the Persians. And so this is, first of all, plausible
把伊斯兰教的崛起背景也联系到鼠疫的背景中，这是可能的吗？还是说这有点过分解读了？我确实这么认为。而且我认为在好几个方面，这确实符合伊斯兰教作为晚期古典时代一部分的故事。这个故事已经被那些对鼠疫不感兴趣的学者们极为丰富地发展了出来，但它确实帮助我们看到：第一，伊斯兰教是一种晚期古典时代的宗教。所以它并不是从我们对晚期古典时代所想象的那些文化世界之外凭空产生的，阿拉伯地区、红海世界在经济、文化和政治上确实与东罗马人和波斯人的世界有着极深的联系。所以，首先这是合理的，
because this is all one big interconnected cultural orbit. And two, the sort of apocalyptic strain of culture in the 6th century and 7th century really transcends any one cultural system. So Christianity, of course, is a religion that has a lot of apocalyptic resources. But there are centuries where Christianity or Christian apocalypticism is fairly muted. You know, if you look in the fourth century, where we have more Christian texts than any other period in antiquity, those authors aren't sort of talking about the imminent judgment and the signs of it
因为这本就是一个巨大的、互联互通的文化轨道。第二，6世纪和7世纪这种末日论色彩的文化，超越了任何单一的文化体系。因此，基督教当然是一个拥有丰富末日资源的宗教。但有些世纪里，基督教或基督教的末日论调是相当低调的。你知道，如果你看看四世纪——我们拥有比古代任何其他时期都多的基督教文本——那些作者并没有喋喋不休地谈论迫在眉睫的审判以及周围的种种迹象，
that are all around them. It's just not what Augustine or Chrysostom or those guys talk about. They think there is going to be a judgment and that we need to prepare for it, but they're not sort of like saying, oh my gosh, here it comes. This is obviously all around us. God is telling us. Whereas the year 500 symbolically does seem to start to stir some apocalyptic belief, so it doesn't come out of nowhere with the plague. But this is how people who live through the plague largely understand it in divine terms and cosmic terms as the sign of the judgment of God. And so it's in the air. part of the Christian and Jewish and ultimately Islamic sort of set of ideas, the stew of ideas that late antique religions are made of, really has these apocalyptic strains in the 6th and 7th century in a way that they didn't in the 4th and 5th century. Well, I think that's really
这些迹象就环绕在他们身边。奥古斯丁或金口约翰或那些人讨论的根本不是这个。他们认为确实会有一场审判，我们需要为此做好准备，但他们并不是那种大喊“天哪，它要来了，这显然就在我们身边，上帝正在告诉我们”的人。然而公元500年这个年份在象征意义上似乎确实开始激发出一些末日信仰，所以它并不是伴随鼠疫凭空出现的。但这就是那些经历过鼠疫的人在神圣和宇宙层面上主要理解它的方式，将其视为上帝审判的迹象。所以这种氛围弥漫在空中。基督教、犹太教以及最终伊斯兰教的一系列思想，即构成晚期古典时代宗教的思想大熔炉，在6世纪和7世纪确实具备了这种末日论调，这是4世纪和5世纪所没有的。好吧，我认为这真的是
absolute tool to force and as kind of as a showcase for how the study of disease can shed light on as titanic a process as the decline and fall of the Roman Empire. So if you've enjoyed this, please do make sure that you go back and listen to the two episodes we released in February where we cover the entire sweep. Thanks so much for this episode and for giving us such an incredible in-depth look at the role of disease over the course of human history. Thank you all so much. Thank you very much. Bye-bye.
一种绝对强大的工具，也是展示疾病研究如何能够阐明像罗马帝国衰亡这样震撼人心的历史进程的一个绝佳范例。所以，如果你喜欢这一集，请务必返回去收听我们在2月发布的两集节目，我们在其中进行了全面的回顾。非常感谢你带来这一集，并为我们深入剖析了人类历史进程中疾病所扮演的令人难以置信的角色。非常感谢大家。非常感谢。再见。
Thanks for listening to The Rest is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest is History）。想要获取独家播客、抢先收听、无广告体验以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、八卦花絮的固定去处，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家播客以及抢先购买现场活动门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。